it's a pleasure to welcome on to the
program representative rokhana he
represents california's 17th
congressional district located in the
heart of silicon valley he is serving
his third term representative khanna is
of course a democrat and for that we're
extremely grateful because it's fun to
have on people from the other party and
actually talk
through the issues representative thanks
so much for joining the show and thank
you for having me on i appreciate the
opportunity yeah you bet so
let's talk about minimum wage because
you sort of made the news uh last week
when you were criticized
uh for some comments you made about the
minimum wage and small businesses the
implications seemed to be that if
businesses weren't paying a higher
minimum wage than maybe they didn't
deserve to be
in business so what did you mean by
those comments
well let me clarify it i am a strong
supporter of small business i understand
the need for small business
i do believe in a 15 minimum wage uh my
belief is that the amazon's targets
walmart's can
uh easily pay that but i understand that
small businesses
uh may have a difficult time in doing
that that's why it needs to be gradual
and that's why we need to have
tax credits and other assistance to
small business uh so that they can do
that
so let's talk about the actual policy
the actual 15 minimum wage so
uh i obviously am an opponent of 15
minimum wage um
when it comes to the minimum wage there
are a bevy of studies including
congressional budget office studies
suggesting that it depresses employment
that for people who actually receive the
minimum wage of course they get paid
more
but for a lot of other people it pushes
them out of the job market because
it is not like businesses actually just
have a giant scrooge mcduck money bank
out back
and they're just holding a bunch of cash
out there in order to somehow
you know disadvantage their employees
that there is a labor market in which
there are a lot of people willing to
work for a particular wage
and that they're paying the labor
essentially what the labor is willing to
accept
in order to work at these particular
jobs when you're talking about
competitive
job markets especially at the lower end
of the wage spectrum isn't it true that
there is a supply and demand issue that
actually develops the wage or
why do you think that it's artificially
low in other words
sure let me suggest the two places we
disagree
uh the your view as i understand it is
this is a contract between
two free individuals why is the
government the state getting involved
and trying to
set the price uh my view is that in
certain cases especially where you have
monopsonies where you have
a high concentration in labor markets
there are only a few buyers
it's not a truly competitive market it's
actually a market failure and so you
have a wage
that is under the competitive market
price in fact milton friedman in 1976
wrote about this possibility that
monopolies could distort
uh the market wage second and i think
this is just a good fake disagreement
uh you would argue people have genuine
bargaining
uh power and you have this concept of
negative freedom that the state should
interfere
my view is that more of positive freedom
that people actually
need uh basic uh support to be able to
bargain effectively
and i don't think that there's true
equal bargaining power often
so there are a couple of issues that i
see in some of the stuff that you're
saying here
uh just on the specific level obviously
the vast majority of of employees at
places like amazon are actually not
making the minimum wage
uh the the fact is that the minimum wage
is only being made by something like 2.3
of all wage earners in the united states
about 50 of those wage earners are under
the age of 25
and when you artificially boost the
minimum wage what you actually end up
doing
is making it harder for people who
actually need the minimum wage jobs to
get those jobs because you have
artificially created
a base in the labor market from which
employers are going to draw so in other
words
a 15 wage is the kind of wage that you
pay to somebody who graduated from
college it's not typically the kind of
wage that you pay for somebody who
graduated from high school
and you see this historically with the
minimum wage when the federal minimum
wage was increased
then people who went to high school had
a much higher employment rate
before and then the minimum wage was
increased and then the unemployment rate
among high school
educated rose dramatically it is not
racially
it is not racially equal that way
actually uh minimum wage increases have
disproportionately had black and brown
people without
college degrees particularly so why is
raising the minimum wage overall a good
idea
well but you're right right now maybe
it's 2.3 i take your
uh word for the study but that's at
seven dollars and 25 cents and
they're 30 million or so of americans
who make between seven dollars and 25
cents and 15
now i think their studies go both ways
some people have argued and there's
studies showing
that it increases productivity it makes
workers
happier it actually uh increases a
business's profitability
i agree there's studies showing that
that may not be the case one
interesting study i saw is that what it
really forces businesses to do
is require high school as a credential
and this a fair point would be
saying that this may make it difficult
more difficult for those who don't
uh haven't finished high school to get
uh one of those jobs
uh but for 90 of americans who have a
high school degree
uh they will be able to get that job and
and pay more so
i guess the studies are in it are there
studies all over the place on this
my view is uh that the country would be
better off
uh with a higher wage that would help
productivity help the happiness of our
employees
i mean the simple kind of rebuttal of
that is if it really impr improved
profitability for businesses to to
provide higher wages than they would do
it meaning you wouldn't need the
government to actually step and enforce
them to do it
being that business businesses are
profit driven primarily
it's a fair point that's if you believe
that businesses always are acting in
their rational long-term interest
my view is that sometimes businesses are
very short-term focused
and may not be making the long-term
investments but
the second case is i mean let me ask you
i mean are there any times you believe
that the government
should interfere for example overtime
laws uh we're required to pay
a time and a half would you support that
i mean there are a lot of times that the
state has made uh regulations to say
that
this helps the bargaining power and
makes for a better labor market yeah and
i'm very much against
virtually all of that i'm extremely
libertarian when it comes to labor
markets particularly because i believe
that monopoly is actually created
by some of the the regulatory
innovations that people have come up
with
in fact i think there's a reason why big
corporations have typically pushed for a
higher minimum wage
when when it becomes clear this is going
to happen because you're right amazon
can absorb that blow a lot more easily
than the mom and pop shop that is down
the street uh it actually
increases their ability to drive other
people out of the market
if everybody is required to pay a higher
wage then amazon can spread that out
over the
over the price of its products it can
spread it out over its 83
market share in like the book market uh
it can it can up charge people
on the product in a way that small mom
and pop stores cannot increase in
minimum wage obviously
disproportionately affects places that
have three employees as opposed to
places
that have 300 employees of which 30 are
actually minimum wage employees
well you're right about that and this is
uh you're right that the
uh impact on certain small businesses is
is harder and that we have to
take action to help those small
businesses i mean i acknowledge that
uh that point i will say though that in
small communities rural communities
often you have the
case that these are highly concentrated
uh markets and in that case you have
uh employers having a lot more monopsony
power
to be able to set the wage and not truly
competitive markets but to the extent
that
my comments in the past were not uh
sensitive enough in the way i phrased it
to the
challenges of small business i
acknowledge that challenge i agree with
you
that it's going to be much harder for
certain small businesses and we have to
be honest about it i mean we can't
i want to engage in an honest
conversation and to pretend that there's
small businesses that aren't going to be
effective
and that should uh be helped would not
be correct
we'll get to more with congressman roe
conov in the 17th district of california
in just one second he's a democrat from
silicon valley let me tell you something
about silicon valley you don't want
those people
to have your data well expressvpn is an
app for your computer and phone that
secures and encrypts your data
so you can have peace of mind every
single time you go online they build a
secure tunnel between your devices and
the internet
by rerouting your connection through
their servers that way your ip address
gets masked and your network data
becomes encrypted
so your isp can't see anything you do
the app connects with just one click it
is lightning fast it is the only vpn i
trust because they use
a trusted server find out how you can
get three months of expressvpn for free
by visiting expressvpn.com
or clicking the link in the description
below it's super easy see
check out my computer see here's
expressvpn it is open and boom
clicking to connect and it's going
connected so now
i'm protected and so is my data that is
the important thing protect your data
today
find out how you can get three months of
expressvpn for free by visiting
expressvpn.com or clicking the link in
the description box below
and the other big problem with a federal
minimum wage is that it is federal
i mean when we're talking about setting
one standard minimum wage across an
entire country
where wages are extremely different in
mississippi than they are in california
in california
a 15 minimum wage in a place like your
district or a place where i was living
until very recently la you get a 15
minimum wage that buys you like a 1
bedroom studio apartment if you get a 15
minimum wage in mississippi that is
literally the median wage in mississippi
right there are states where there are
wildly disparate numbers as far as
what wages are actually worth in
particular states why in the world would
the federal government set a federal
minimum wage that is so high
that it is actually at or close to i
believe the median wage in mississippi
right now is 14 23 an hour why would
they set a median wage
a minimum wage that is above the median
wage in a place like mississippi
when a minimum wage in california 15 an
hour basically buys you a candy bar
well again this is the debate about the
floor i agree with you in my district 15
isn't enough and the question is could
should there be reasonable variance yes
and then the question becomes what is
the floor i mean we have a federalist
system so there's a real easy
solution here right i mean we actually
have like cities and states and they
could do this sort of thing
right but the question is there should
be a national floor and now i'm saying
the floor should be 15
do you believe there should be any floor
i mean do you think i mean 725 i think
is
unreasonable i mean for example uh
cotton and romney have said the floor
should be ten dollars uh
i think holly is saying it should be
fifteen dollars but for billion
corporations
where would you set the floor i mean
there there is a i mean unfortunately
there is a floor and the floor is zero
and it's going to be felt by 1.4 million
people who won't have a job come 2025 if
we raise this to
15 minimum wage i guess my question is
for you would you support
any national federal minimum wage at any
standard
no i mean again i think free labor is is
is able to bargain and if you can come
up with a case where you have an
actual monopoly that is that is
violating labor law
in its attempts to cram down a wage on a
person who's unwilling to accept it
first of all we have an amendment to the
constitution that prevents involuntary
servitude
and second of all bargaining power is
still a thing i mean the the fact is
that
there are wages that people cannot
charge because people will not take the
jobs for those wages i mean that does
exist and by the way if you're worried
about
wages being depressed then there's a
case to be made that one of the things
we should be worried about is
is cracking down on businesses that are
using illegal immigration in states like
california for example
well what would you say to uh the
argument for monopsony which even
friedman
argues now he in fairness he says this
is a rare case and
he was against minimum wage i mean just
confirm this but he says look there are
cases
where you have one or two employers in a
town
and they're not charging a competitive
price because you don't have the choice
to go to four or five different
employers
and in those cases uh it's a market
failure
that certainly seems as one case and
then we can disagree about uh
negotiating but i guess the broader
point for uh
in my opinion is because i believe in
entrepreneurship i believe in innovation
i believe in
capitalism i call myself a progressive
capitalist is when we're producing such
incredible wealth
trillions of dollars in my district uh
the ability to have
people earn uh a wage that allows them
to live a decent life seems to be
something that's good for our democracy
yeah i mean
my counterpoint is that we are not
producing incredible wealth these
companies are producing
incredible wealth because they know how
to run the business better than members
of government who are
you know getting their salary from me
frankly
and and from these businesses that
actually are paying extraordinary levels
of tax
representative rokhana i really
appreciate you coming on the program and
it's great to have conversations like
this
so thank you for reaching out cause you
reached out after i i think i noted
something on on the show about your
comments and so it's great to have you
on to clarify your position on this and
i think it's really important to do it
so
again just want to thank you for your
time well i appreciate that and i
appreciate you are having a very civil
reasonable exchange the one place we
agree
upon is you said that i've read
somewhere that you believe rational
debate
uh is what's necessary in our democracy
uh and i wish we had more exchanges like
this
across the country i really appreciate
it and um i i certainly hope that you're
not canceled for having appeared on the
show
representative we'll see exactly
representative rochon a democrat of
california
really appreciate the time thank you so
much thank you i hope you enjoyed that
clip from the ben shapiro show if you
did go ahead and hit the subscribe
button so you stay up to date on all of
our future content